I have one question and one question
only do you like games
because if you do check out full sales
they're sponsoring this miniseries Full
Sail University creates video games so
if you want to study making games just
like this check out a link in the
description maybe I'll play your game
one day I think if I could go back in
time I would have loved to so it's cool
- all right yes yes yes I knew that
come on nice you hit the ball oh my god
who's on the losing side so far you
candor man I'm gonna get both Candyman
trips oh I can't when I'm dead Jesus
Candyman stopping versus Scrabble
Oh oh my god oh my god I lost you're
serious pick flip it Jordy kickflip it
charging it for that month Oh gotta win
this for my father
no all right well we do never rematch
none another rematch is not fair
rematch all right I'm gonna win this
guy's trust me skateboarding skills made
oh my god no I got teleportation do that
Oh dirty your mind yes excellent
oh right indicated mate oh my god
felix is one life I have two lives I can
delete any lives you don't know that's
rad don't do it don't do it I'm doing
this I'm literally just clicking buttons
that's pretty much oh there we go don't
do that don't do oh my God where did it
go yes come on and the leading is
channel oh my god jelly actually [ __ ]
win no no no no no no no oh [ __ ]
Timmy Timmy Timmy Timmy coming you can
aim upwards when you shoot oh you can't
oh I didn't know that one do this Christ
what are you doing
how did I lose to you go buy jelly
oh my god this is so intense oh well
then quit quit
I guess guess we got to do it jelly yeah
delete your town will get it click on
the button believe delete your channels
okay
delete it doing it it's supposed to
leave it's gone god
hi Prez thanks for watching this video
I guess my channel will live another day
because youtube doesn't seem to allow a
huge thanks to full sales for sponsoring
this miniseries I think it's really cool
if I could go back in time I would love
to study game development I lucked out
somehow so basically if you're
interested in that sort of thing check
out a link in the description why not
fall out fall of your heart that's all
I'm gonna say but also thank you so much
for watching and as always stay awesome